단순 계산으로 거의 한 825억
[음악]
한 100억 정도 받았고요 대지가
216평 그리고 연면적이
743평입니다
굉장히 커요 그리고 지하 2층에 지상
5층 규모고요 건축물대장을 좀 한번
볼게요 건물 항상 보실 때
토지이용계획을 보셔야 돼요 그래서
토지이용계획 보면 2종 일반주거지역
바로 나와야죠 저희 구독자 분들 건물
60%에
용적률 200% 그래서 지금이 건물은
216%로 16% 더 받았어요 그래서
예전에 지은 건물이다 보니까
용적률을 더 받은 상태고요 건물은
되게 꽉 차 있는 건물이고 제가 그때
당시에 봤을 때
구조가 조금 특이하긴 했어요 내부
구조가 내 당시에도 되게 괜찮은
매물이었었거든요 그때 평 대지
평단가로 봤을 때 한 6천대에 나와
있었는데 그 인근 시세보다도 되게 좀
저렴하게 나와 있던 건물에서 저도
되게 급하게 가서
봤던 기억이 좀 있습니다 지금 여기
인근에 팔린 건물들이 이쪽에 있는
건물이 한 대지 평당가로 한 1억
7천 그리고 여기 밑에 있는게
중간 1억 7,8000 정도에
팔렸어요 올해 팔린 거 같은데 그리고
요쪽 이면에 있는게 한 뭐 1억 9천
2억 좀 안 되게 매각이 됐고요
그래서 뭐 이거를 그냥 단순 계산으로
봤을 때 돼지가 216평 제가 봤을
때는 최소한 1억 5천은 할 거
같아요 한 320억이 넘습니다 그래서
기사에 나왔던
300억
맞습니다네 맞고 심지어 더 됩니다 더
될 것으로 좀 예상이 되고 그리고
연면적 자체도 워낙 크고 그때 당시에
건물을 너무 잘 샀습니다 부부
공동명의로
매입해가지고 가지고 있고요
추가적으로도 설명드리면 그 원빈님은
여기 성수동에도 건물을 샀었어요
그래서
2014년도에 이쪽에 있는 건물을
20억 원에 샀습니다 아직도 기억나요
저희 2014년도에
매입하자마자 제가 또 현장 가서
봤었는데 그때 당시에는 이렇게
아뜰리에 길이 되게 개발되거나 그런
상황이 아니었었어요 그래서 어 이거
왜 샀지라고 했었는데
그때 한 3,000 정도에 샀어요
돼지 평당 그래서 그때 뭐 답사를
갔던 좀 기억이 있는데 좀 성수동이
개발될 거를 미리 좀 파악을 하고
그때 당시 좀 투자를 했습니다 여기
이면에 보통 팔리는게 1억 한 초중반
정도에 팔리거든요 그때 대비해서도
4배 정도 오른 것 같습니다 그래서
원빈 님은 제가 봤을 때는 뭐 투자에
좀 일가견이 있으신 거 같습니다
청담동도 그때 당시에 되게 좀 저렴한
가격에
매입해 가지고 지금까지 가지고 있고요
저는 심지어
원빈이랑 이나영 부부보다 여기 건너편
대로변에 있는 대성림이 더 많이
벌었습니다
학동사거리역이 대로변 여기 스타벅스
들어가 있는 건물 그래서 필지를
보면은 여기 세필지를 가지고 계세요
그래서 이번주 6번지 13 14번지
주차는 여기 뒤로 이렇게 내놨고
그래서 이제 전면이 좀 살았고요이
건물을
2017년도에 310억에 샀습니다
310억 대성님이 90 89년생이세요
그래서 저랑
얼마
차이가 안 나더라구요 대성님이 그때
그때가 89년 되면은
20대 후반인데 그때 이제 여기
도산대로의 건물을 샀습니다 310억에
엄청 많이 올랐거든요 예전에 저희
비산tv 영상 보시면은 제가 엄청 잘
샀다고 해가지고 촬영했던 적 있는데
이거랑 아마 전지현님 거랑 같이
비교해서
촬영을 했었는데 그 사이에 시세가
굉장히 많이 올랐습니다요 대성님 건물
같은 경우에는 제가 봤을 때 최소
3억 이상이거든요 돼지 평당가 여기
코너 변에 있던게
작년에 한 3억 3,4000 정도에
팔렸어요 대지간 310평 뭐이 정도
됐었는데 1005억 정도에 팔렸습니다
대성님께 대지가 275평이에요
연면적이 1,218평
용적률이 한 300% 정도 되고요
310억에 살 때 170억 정도 받은
거 같아요 대출을 단순 계산으로 거의
한 825억
최소 825억입니다 최소 최소
3억이에요 지금
땅도 너무 좋구요 지금 여기이면
도로도 끼고 있고 그리고 합동사거리
역도 생기죠 위례 신사선으로
들어옵니다 그래서 지금 원빈님이
아니라 지금 대성님이 훨씬 많이
어떻게 보면 차익이 더 커요 더 말을
못 하겠습니다 이게 뭐 사실 이렇게
계속 얘기하면 좀 계속 현타오거든요
이거는 사실 갖고 있으면 계속 버는
부동산이에요 이거는 대성리 거는 워낙
위치도 좋고 그때 당시에 너무 잘
샀고 그때 당시에는 위에 이제
전광판도 있는데
옆에 건물을 신축하면서 없앤 거
같아요네 아무래도 좀 잘 보이지
않으니까
근데 위치 자체가 너무 좋아서 이거는
진짜 그냥
평생 가지고 있어도 될 만한
부동산이고 제가 제일 사고 싶은
도로에 제일 사고 싶은 위치에 있는
건물입니다 지금 정리해보면 제가 항상
얘기하는 주요 지역에 가격이 좀 더
비싸더라도 위치 좋은 거를
매입하자라는 말씀을 좀 드리고 싶고요
아무래도 그러면은 주변에 계속
최고가를 찍어 줘요 그리고
그렇게 건물이 팔리면 또 그렇게
개발도 됩니다 비용이 많이 들어서 또
개발도 되고 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다